jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
vorsitzenden der fdp-fraktion und das
ist wie wir alle wissen christian
lindner der redner der afg hat hier eben
von einem erfundenen weltuntergang
gesprochen ich bin öfter in unserem mal
ihre diktion zu verwenden ich bin öfter
im deutschen wald und wer angesichts des
zustandes des deutschen waldes den
klimawandel leugnet der kann ihre heimat
nicht kennen der kann die deutsche
heimat vor allen dingen nicht lieben
aber keinen sinn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen mal damen
und herren es macht keinen sinn einen
falschen klima absolutismus mit dem
leugnen des klimawandels zu beantworten
frau bundeskanzlerin sie amtieren jetzt
14 jahre sie sind sehr lange auch als
klimakanzlerin ja bezeichnet worden
und tatsächlich deutschland hat ja große
anstrengungen in der klimapolitik
bereits in den vergangenen jahren vor
ihrer amtszeit und während ihrer
amtszeit übernommen
die summe der auszahlungen aus dem
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz während
ihrer amtszeit belaufen sich auf über
300 milliarden euro
wir reden jetzt lieber 54 milliarden
während ihrer amtszeit sind bereits über
300 milliarden euro von den stromkunden
und stromkunden gezahlt worden wegen
ökologischer motive herr brinkhaus wenn
sie dann heute davon sprechen und sie
wollen mehr klimaschutz und mehr zu dann
will ich ihn angesichts der finanziellen
größenordnungen der vergangenen
jahrzehnte sagen wir brauchen nicht mehr
wir brauchen besseren klimaschutz als im
vergangenen jahr
er konnte ihr leben gern herr kollege
lindner der kollege hinzu für die gerne
eine zwischenfrage stellen einen das
thema fds bereits erledigt
wenn man jetzt das paket im einzelnen
sieht so gibt es licht und schatten ja
gut ist es das getan wird endlich etwas
für die energetische gebäudesanierung
bahn investitionen eines der größten
programme der geschichte wenn ich gar
das größte programm das begrüßen wir
aber es gibt auch schattenseiten
also beispielsweise die erhöhung der
preise für flugtickets
selbst wenn das einen effekt hat dass
die menschen weniger in deutschland
fliegen
aufgrund des europäischen
zertifikatehandel so der mangelnden
abstimmung mit europäischen instrumenten
wird es zu einem wasserbett effekt
kommen das heißt anderswo in europa wird
es günstiger werden weil es bei uns
teurer wird für das weltklima ist damit
nichts gerettet und im übrigen auch im
übrigen auch erbringt auswendig ihre
rede verfolgen
da war wieder die einseitige fixierung
auf batterie elektrische antriebe
einseitige ja aber da nein es war wir
können ja ihre rede noch einmal
auswerten und auszählen die oft batterie
elektrisches von ihnen genannt morgen
ist und wie selten das feigenblatt sie
wollten auch etwas tun für wasserstoff
genannt worden ist und dass ihr problem
sie sind eben nicht in wahrheit
technologieoffen damit werden große
chancen ausgeschlagen für die
wertschöpfungsketten nicht nur unsere
industrie sondern auch für den
klimawandel
denn mit synthetischen kraftstoffe kann
selbst der golf 2 des jahres 1985 zu
einem klimaneutralen fahrzeug werden
aber genau solche technologie optionen
werden von ihnen ausgebremst da könnte
man im übrigen auch mal groß denken wenn
wir die chancen tätiger kraftstoffe
nehmen würden könnte man groß denken bei
heizungen ob ein flugzeug beim auto man
könnte auch mal global denken
die desertec-initiative seinerzeit
gescheitert auch an physikalischen
fragen
man kann eben aus der wüste nicht ohne
weiteres mit leitungen strom
um den norden bringen aber möglich wäre
es in afrika mit erneuerbarer energie
synthetische kraftstoffe zu produzieren
die wir dann über die übliche
infrastruktur in deutschland stichwort
tankstelle und pipeline verteilen können
wohlstand dort klimaschutz bei uns in
der globalen perspektive wo ist ein
solches denken wo es ein solches denken
wir reden hier über eine
menschheitsaufgabe
und wie kleinteilig aktionistisch wirkt
dieses programm angesichts der dimension
über die wir sprechen müssen
frau bundeskanzlerin wir haben oft genug
das würde ich noch sagen respekt
ausgedrückt gegenüber aktivisten und wir
teilen die anerkennung politischen
engagement
ich fand es aber insbesondere richtig
dass sie völlig überzogene rhetorik und
völlig überzogene forderungen auch
einmal in die schranken gewiesen haben
wie sie das unlängst bei ihrem besuch in
den vereinigten staaten getan haben
bei allem respekt vor engagement
wir dürfen uns auch nicht in den panik
modus von greta thunberg reden lassen
die erderwärmung bekämpft man nur mit
grünem kopf meine damen und herren
und es hiervon von frau schulze und
herrn brinkhaus der emissionshandel
gelobt worden
das begrüßen wir
gäbe es ein emissionshandel wir würden
es begrüßen
ein marktwirtschaftliches modell aber
begrenzt die menge und setzt nicht den
preis fest
eine steuer begrenzt nicht die menge
sondern die legt einen preis fest was
genau haben sie vorgelegt festpreise
preiskorridor aber keine steuerung eben
über die menge denn die ist nicht
begrenzt das was die co2 emissionshandel
nennen
in wahrheit ist es eine verkappte co2
steuer
meine damen und herren und daran werden
sich daran werden sich jetzt rechtliche
fragen knüpfen da sage ich ihnen für die
weiteren beratungen zu wir werden darauf
achten dass wir nur dinge beschließen
die mit dem grundgesetz vereinbar sind
und wenn sich herausstellt dass ihr
emissionshandel in wahrheit eine co2
steuer ist dann werden wir in ganz
anderer weise darüber sprechen eins ist
jedenfalls klar
mit dem modell wie sie es vorgelegt
haben ohne mengen grenze dafür mit preis
eins ist klar dass co2 teuer wird das
ist klar aber ob die verteuerung von co2
tatsächlich zu einer verhaltensänderung
führt und nicht nur wie bei der
ökosteuer der vergangenheit zum
abkassieren
das ist eine reine wette die sie
eingehen wir würden es gerne anders
machen preis wird am markt fest gesetzt
aber die absolute menge ist von der
politik begrenzen das wäre ein sauberes
modell
christian lindner fühle die fdp fraktion
jetzt kommt carsten hilse aus der
fdp-fraktion doch noch zu wort
die kurzintervention prävention zu
lassen schade herr linder dass ich die
zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen haben das
ja ja ich weiß nicht ob sie angst haben
keine ahnung
sie haben gesagt dass die ard den
klimaleugner oder das klima leugne
ich möchte noch einmal betonen
klimawandel ist ein natürliches phänomen
seit hunderten millionen von jahren
wer das läuten dann würde der wäre
natürlich dumm wir sagen dass ein
natürliches phänomen wir sagen einfach
nur dass der mensch mit seinen co2
emissionen nicht maßgeblich zu diesem
klimawandel beiträgt das ist alles was
wir sagen und schön dass ihr in ihrer
rede wieder mal etwas geklaut haben von
der afg weil wir waren die ersten die
synthetische kraftstoffe hier im
bundestag eingebracht haben
[Applaus]
mögen sie antworten herr kollegen
hindern kollege ihr beitrag spricht für
sich ich wünsche ihm große verbreitung
und damit meint er sicherlich auch das
97,7 prozent aller wissenschaftler vom
gegenteil dessen ausgehen was auch
carsten hülse hier eben propagiert hat